tell me if you're familiar with this
girl do you know who lana rhodes is yeah
okay so here's a little quick uh quick
clip shout out to rich cooper
entrepreneurs and cars
don't get upset with us if we play this
clip we're giving you a shout out bro
let's play this quick let us have your
content
atlanta rhodes is a porn star she's
sitting here lecturing on what trophy
wife training looks like with her two
other friends so all in all a trophy
wife is a high value woman in our eyes
she works on bettering herself every
single day whether it's physically
mentally educating herself she dresses
for herself not for other people and she
just loves herself and puts all her
energy and effort into building herself
she talks about what trophy or wife
training looks like from the perspective
of hypergamy she completely butchers
what hypergamy is they also talk
throughout this cast about this term bad
[ __ ]
men don't care about being around women
that have bad attitudes they don't want
to be around you know miserable women
that think that they're bad [ __ ] why
are they not showing you know women how
to make a sandwich it's just them
talking about her past in porn her giant
notch camp which she suspects guys
should look away from it's pretty gross
if i'm being honest
okay
so
lana rhodes
a friend of yours
uh i'm i wouldn't say
i mean i know her we're not friends
would you what are your thoughts on her
concept of being a trophy wife and even
a bad [ __ ] and your thoughts on hey
listen nobody cares about you being a
bad [ __ ] and having a bad attitude go
make a sandwich
that was essentially the context of that
clip well why are you watching her
podcast in the first place sorry rich
but like what like this is what he does
he watches the types of intersexual
dynamics
i i mean i don't think what she said in
the beginning part i don't know what she
said the whole bad [ __ ] thing other
than what he
emulated kind of thing of her i don't
think what she's saying is wrong i don't
know if the whole context of saying
trophy write trophy wife
whatever what was she trying to say that
was the like the standards i don't
relate in the context
yeah she's trying to say that that's
what the truth
yes like that's the characteristics
i don't think what she's saying is wrong
i don't know the whole rest of the
context of certain things you know i
mean like i said the badge [ __ ] thing
but i mean the sandwich part it's very
sexist uh
you know i mean
it is what it is i think everybody has
their own opinion like at the end of the
day
everybody has their own opinion about
what a trophy wife is how triggering the
word trophy right even says to me
because that means that you're like up
here on some pedestal you you know
you're doing all these things like
i just don't like that is that you would
you not want to be put on a pedestal and
make a trophy i maybe that's
no i wouldn't i wouldn't be on a
pedestal but like trophy wife like what
is that you don't like that terminology
right now like if your husband boyfriend
was like babe i'm hungry would you make
me a sandwich one thousand and ten
percent you would do it yeah okay i'm
getting kind of hungry about that
i'm not your wife
yeah
just kidding i'm not 20 either so that's
true
[Laughter]
um if your husband asked you to make a
sandwich would you make him a sandwich i
always make him sandwich oh do you cut
off the crust no because he likes the
crust okay but that's the thing is like
the whole thing is what she's saying is
like she talked about like i feel like
as a woman of things that you do i think
that that's part of being a woman in
general you know and being a wife adds
on
responsibilities if that's what your you
know thing is if it's making a sandwich
having the kids
supporting what working roles or
whatever it may be i just don't think it
needs to be it's not like that's not the
end-all be-all definition the problem
that i have with that uh
video is i've heard i heard myself
more than any other word in it it was
like myself myself myself myself if
you're a trophy wife or a trophy
uh mom right let's just add that your
focus is not on yourself it's on but
you're also looking at someone who's not
a wife
so therefore the context is what her own
opinion is is why i think is everybody's
standards are different wearing yourself
is you have a partner who you include
both of you and those things where i
feel like it's like okay she's not wrong
all the way off but
she's not a wife yeah and you have to
better yourself like i better myself
every single day but it's
to serve my
relationship and my family and that's
that i think that's where
there's
issues with what she says because i've
seen a couple clips about it too
and it's like myself like i have to do
everything for myself right and that's
an issue that i feel is with is
happening with women it's all about the
self
whereas like in a relationship we have
to give i give a hundred and fifty
percent of myself to my family
and then i focus and then i
see what i need to do for myself
again i'm not married i can't and again
that works for you but again like i
don't think that it depends on where you
want to like
each individual is different so some
people have may have to focus on
themselves first to be the better
partner to be the better whatever be to
fulfill those things you don't need that
and that could be fine but some people
maybe like with myself how i talked
about me doing inner work for myself i
personally had to like turn in because
i'm like okay if i'm like certain
something has to be accountable right
like obviously i'm the only one left
standing here so it's me so it's like
what what am i doing wrong or what am i
doing whatever so until i got to the
core of those real answers was i really
and before i was saying i wanted a date
two years ago i wasn't really ready to
date because i had such high walls
because i couldn't serve myself any
justice because i didn't know what was
wrong internally so therefore i would
make a horrible partner
because i couldn't really give you my
whole being
so
that's something that you have to do
beforehand before you but also in
relationships i think that that's you
know myself when i was married i lost
who i was as a person because i was
bettering him it was all about him it
wasn't now again it wasn't the us it was
him so that's wrong as well too it's to
figuring out the balance of what works
for you is why i always say like what
works for you may not work for me what
works for you may not work for you know
vice versa
this whole idea of like what's supposed
to be like you're supposed to have
married and 2.5 kids or whatever it's
unrealistic not everybody does those
things not everybody goes into
relationships the same some people don't
stay in relationships the same and it's
just i feel like people are too judgy of
what a dictator what a trophy wife is or
what we're supposed to do like let
people be people let people live their
own life like why does it have to be so
stigmatized of like oh she said
something bad the girls aren't even
married she just had a baby she just had
whatever like she knew on her podcast
like she proves she doesn't know how to
talk to people certain times or like
what how to say like it's growth like as
long as there's room for growth and
accountability and i then i feel like
good for you
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire sauce cast click right
here
[Music]